if you're feeling a palpable sexual
excitement in the air it's probably
because the vice presidential debate was
tonight oh there's a tim kaine and Mike
Pence otherwise known as white guy 37b
and white guy 55 c squared up hang on
that's mr. Belding and the dead from
that 70 show Jack we please put up the
right photos no Jack that has met
flavors in a bowl of rice please find
photos of VP candidates all right that's
better yeah since we were busy taping at
the time we didn't get to see the debate
as it happened so we're just assuming it
at some point harmonic enthusiast Tim
Kaine did a bitchin duet with John
popper from Blues Traveler and that Mike
Pence revealed he's been a dummy
controlled by Jeff Dunham this entire
time either way Americans know next to
nothing about these two so comedians
what's a question they should have been
asked to get to the core of these
store-brand white guys Louie Anderson
have you ever owned stock and Cracker
Barrel points are you Cracker Barrel
Brendon Walsh what's your favorite Jimmy
Buffett song and you can't say all of
them yes points Martha Kelly Oh should
21st century American women be allowed
to get abortions or just fake boobs
hahahaha boards